in this video we're going to add and
subtract negative numbers on a number
line and the important thing to realize
is if you are adding a positive number
you start at some point on the number
line and you move that many units to the
right
if you are adding a negative number you
start it wherever you're starting and
then you move that many units to the
left whatever the absolute value of that
negative number is and if you're
subtracting either of them you do the
opposite so we're going to see a few
examples of that so let's start with
this first example negative 10 plus
negative 6. so we're going to start at
negative 10 right over here so let's
look at that on the number line that's a
negative 10 right over there we're going
to start over there and then we are
adding positive 6. so what do we do well
we start here
and as I mentioned we're going to go six
units to the right because it's a
positive 6. so 1 2 3 4 5 6.
so we're going to go right over there
we started at the negative 10 and since
we're adding positive 6 we go 6 units to
the right and we end up right over here
at negative four so this is equal to
negative 4. now let's do this one where
are we starting we are starting at
negative 8 so that's negative 10
negative 9 negative 8 is right over
there
now we're going to subtract negative 2.
so let's be very careful here if we were
adding negative 2 we would go two units
to the left like that but we're
subtracting negative 2 so we're going to
do the opposite we're going to instead
instead of going two units to the left
we're going to go 2 units to the right
so we're going to go one two units to
the right and we are going to end up
right over there so that's negative 7
negative 6. so this is equal to negative
6. remember if we were adding negative 2
we would have gone two units to the left
but when you subtract you do the
opposite of what you would have
otherwise done so now we're going two
units to the right even though it's a
negative 2 because we're subtracting
negative 2. all right we're starting at
4 in the third example
so we're starting right over here at 4.
and we are adding negative 7. so
negative seven you're just going to move
the absolute value of that to the left
so the absolute value of negative seven
is just seven so you're going to move
seven units to the left and we're not
subtracting that so we're just going to
just move seven units to the left we're
not going to do the opposite of that or
anything like that so we just go seven
units to the left we're adding negative
seven so one two three four five six
seven we end up right over here
so we have positive four minus seven
we've gone seven years to the left and
now we're at let's see this is zero
negative one negative two negative three
so that is equal to negative three
now this last one try to do it on your
own before we do it together
all right now some of you might be
tempted to say oh five and negative five
aren't those additive inverses don't
those just cancel out well they would if
you were adding five plus negative five
is equal to zero but here we're doing
five minus negative five so let's just
do it step by step we're starting at
five
now if we were adding negative 5 to that
we would go five units to the left and
we would end up at zero but we are not
adding negative five we are subtracting
negative five so instead of going five
units to the left we're going to go five
units to the right so one two three four
five we end up right over there
and so we end up at 10.
and we are done